a new study on the effectiveness of face
masks shows a dramatic life-saving
result against the corona virus
researchers from Arizona State
University found that widespread use of
masks even if they're homemade could
lower the projected death toll in New
York State by up to forty five percent
over two months
Vlad duje reports on how Americans
nationwide seem to be getting the
message to cover up everywhere in
America people stepped up to answer the
call with a cloth thread and a needle
it's just been uplifting to be able to
have someone who's due and to have a
purpose we start off a mask by sewing in
the protection from a nine year old girl
in Maryland working in her basement to
this 90 year old man in Wisconsin and
you got the material and I started
sewing people are sewing masks for
medical workers first responders and for
themselves you can see the hidden
talents behind those hidden faces the
creative ones and the wacky ones
repurposed dress shirts classic bandanas
and masks with artwork by children in
hospitals the new normal when life gives
you cloth you make masks here's how you
can make your own face covering in a few
easy steps when the nation's top doctor
urged everyone to make their own face
covering Americans started looking for
anything and everything they could find
at home very simple fabric mask that I
made out of a t-shirt without any sewing
you take handkerchiefs like this size
this is a a which people use for a
variety of things um you know save
concept where you would basically make
sure that it covers your nose and make
sure that it covers the chin exactly
exactly that's perfect we asked our
senior medical correspondent dr. taryn
Rula for some guidance you want it to be
in the right position on your nose which
is kind of exactly where you have it it
should fall right in the bridge of your
nose not too low and then you want to
make sure it comes under your chin as
well what are some of the mistakes that
people make when they're wearing it one
word fidgeting you tend to touch it a
lot and pull it up pull it down and
is potentially getting their hands on
the mask dirty and contaminated from
this t-shirt company in California shut
down it switched to making masks and
gave away tens of thousands for free we
all need them and we're trying to stay
safe and protect everyone small
businesses to big companies everyone is
pitching in under armour repurpose their
Baltimore operations to produce roughly
six hundred and fifty thousand masks for
health care workers it was just simply
the right thing to do
CEO Patrick frisk we've had our
teammates at Under Armour step up and
truly live our values in this very
difficult time check out some of these
Anthony made by sue Segal who was a
seamstress for prints and check out
these masks from Universal Music Group
branded by some of its top artists the
Rolling Stones Queen Bob Marley Billy
Eilish Justin Bieber Ariana Grande all
proceeds will go to a Relief Fund for
struggling artists I know you got one
already I did I got this I usually wear
bandanas but I kind of like this one
because it it feels like it gives me a
face again or at least lips glad I did
see what your bandana but I love this
better there's a different slightly
different look thanks a lot